well here now are duly on when she's the
chief executive of the joseph rowntree
foundation which looks at poverty in the
UK and [ __ ] and deputy director of the
adam smith institute think tank welcome
to you both now this whole idea of an
integrated tax and benefit system was
rattlers have built up really by Gordon
Brown both as Chancellor and then as
Prime Minister is what we're seeing a
reversal of that are sort of different
philosophical approach do you think no I
think what we're seeing is the building
up of Universal Credit which comes
precisely from that background which is
you try and make the movement from work
into an out of work as smooth as
possible to incentivize people going
into work of course going to work must
be the best thing people can do but our
current labor market is very uncertain
very precarious people go in and out of
work never out of poverty and we need a
benefit system that supports them in
doing that in the hope and expectation
they will stay and work long-term work
where they can make their lives and
support their families I'm presumably we
do that and you cut credits in work
benefits then people going to have a
bless at the end of the day well that's
true yeah if you cut credit without
cutting cutting taxes then your
disincentive icing work you're reducing
what you get when you go in and the
prime minister said today that we should
be moving away from the system where
we're taxing people and then give them
the benefits back and I think that's
right but the problem is we're not
cutting taxes at the same rate that were
cutting benefits and if we just hit this
approach with just looks at the deficit
and doesn't try and reduce the cost of
living by making supply-side reforms and
doesn't try and focus big tax cuts on
the working poor and that means national
insurance thresholds being risen as well
as raising the personal allowance then I
think we're going to leave people worse
off and we may disincentivize work I
mean the poorest people are not paying
income tax under 10,000 you're not
paying income tax a national sure but
they are indeed national eating bathroom
and they're paying very regressive
consumption tax because actually the
costs for an average household are much
greater the poorer you are this bigger
proportion of your spending goes on food
dispensers we're talking about
incentivizing work then making work pay
is the best way to do that we both agree
absolutely agreement undie Betty the
easiest way to do that is to raise the
national insurance threshold hopefully
actually peg it and the personal
allowance to the minimum wage rate so
the part-time minimum-wage workers
aren't paying tax at all and i think i
think the rhetoric that we heard today
sound the actual results that we're
going to see I probably let you do that
I would I don't think that raising
personal tax allowance is a very
efficient way to expensive way what was
about moving up with the minimum wage
well we certainly need to increase the
minimum wage to honor the commitment
that was made the tripartite committee
between industry trade unions and
government to keep the minimum wage at a
level which people were so that's moving
towards living with yes and I'm sure
that's the right thing to do and both of
us would agree on that as well no
certainly not it's a terrible idea the
minimum wage we know there is a huge
amount of empirical evidence this isn't
just theory mrs. evidence that the
minimum wage cut causes jobs yeah hits
jobs there is no magic wand well with
all his route mean I remember when it
was introduced gonna cost three million
jobs they didn't that's true but he has
got very high levels of employment now
but we have over a hundred very very
good economic studies that I mean that's
one instance that's one data point but
we have studies that look at different
US states where one has risen the
minimum wage and one hasn't that make
very very sophisticated approaches and
most of them not all of them but most of
them showed that the minimum wage does
cost jobs and there really is no magic
one that we can use to boost incomes and
work there is no magic wand but if four
out of five people who start work lowly
paid are still lowly paid ten years on
we've got to do something about the
productivity of British industry so that
those people can earn more and can
progress in companies where they can
make their way we're not a joke about
that I mean we are if the minimum wage
goes up we're also talking about the
public sector where really how people
work yes so we're contributing to making
the country work we do we do need to
make sure that people can live lives
without being entirely dependent on
benefits currently the benefit system is
underpinning some pretty low page so if
this 12 billion is going to be found
we're told from welfare cuts is that
fair is that anti anti egalitarian anti
fairer society I think it depends where
the axe Falls focusing on tax quite the
tax credits alone i think is a bad idea
housing benefit could be cut if we build
more houses the government could do that
okay it can reform planning and the cost
of housing will fall pretty quickly
because that the cost of houses now
people will know that they'll be less
valuable in five years so it will fall
now so that would work but even on the
minimum wage point lots of people who
receive tax
let's get term child tax credits and
they don't earn the minimum wage raising
the minimum wage not won't do anything
for them the best thing we can do for
people like that is reform child care
regulations so that it's cheaper to send
a kid to a crash it's cheaper to get
reminders and the UK has such strict the
UK is the strictest child care
regulations in Europe much stricter than
Germany or Denmark or Sweden and there
we really don't have anything to show
for it those countries don't have
terrible child care systems but we just
spend much much more is if her no doubt
that child care needs a lot of
expenditure to get it going so that
people can go to work nobody will go to
work and leave their children unless
they feel safe and confident we need a
good properly supported child care
system and with you on that we need to
build more housing we need some of that
to be subsidized for people who'll never
be able to buy that takes time is it
fair I've we've been arguing for decades
that you need to reform welfare of
course you do need to make it fit for
the modern economy if you try and do it
in a rush you knock out ten percent of
the benefit system in an announcement we
made in a fortnight's time you're
playing with fire because you're risking
the lives of some very poor people I
mean they're people who say on the right
that it was a fair thing to do actually
be to not ring-fenced pensioners there's
something I think that's key I mean the
pensions that the pensions budget this
year is 92 billion pounds and the triple
lock means that even though inflation is
zero and we're wagering have risen very
strongly this year so we're increasing
pensions by probably about two point six
percent this year looking at the wages
are growing so far I mean that's
incredible there's no increase in the
cost of living but we're still good
we're still committing to massively
increase the pensions budget freezing
that just just dropping the triple lock
and looking at inflation alone would
allow us to freeze the pensions budget
that's a huge saving and they're also
currently the way the cuts proposed it
will impact on working age adults yeah
is that fair no I don't think it's fair
when we have an economy which doesn't
provide for stability and work what
about the end austerity marches of the
weekend I mean they would say that you
can make this up by increasing taxes at
the top end or the better off i don't i
don't think that's something I'm
equipped to even talk about what matters
is how you divide up the benefits bill
as it is now and how you plan for a
future you can't do these things
short-term you could plan in just the
way that sounds
I